The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL PERRONE: So my name's
Michael Perrone.
I'm at the T.J. Watson Research
Center, IBM research.
Doing all kinds of things for
research, but most recently--
that's not what I want.
There we go.
Most recently I've been
working with the cell
processor for the past
three years or so.
I don't want that.
How's that?
And because I do have to run
out for a flight, I have my
e-mail here if you want
to ask me questions,
feel free to do that.
What I'm going to do in this
presentation is as Saman
suggested, talk in depth about
the cell processor, but really
it's still going to be just the
very surface because you
going to have a month to go
into a lot more detail.
But I want to give you a sense
for why it was created, the
way it was created, what it's
capable of doing, and what are
the programming considerations
that have to be taken in mind
when you program.
Here's the agenda just
for this section,
Mike, of this class.
I'll give you some motivation.
This is going to be a bit of a
repeat, so I'll go through it
fairly quickly.
I'll talk about the design
concepts, hardware overview,
performance characteristics,
application affinity--
what good is this device?
Talk about the software and this
I imagine is one of the
areas where you're going to go
into a lot of detail in the
next month because as you
suggested, the software really
is the issue and I would
actually go a little further
and say, why do people drive
such large cars in the U.S.?
Why do they waste
so much energy?
The answer is very simple.
It's because it's cheap.
Even at $3 a gallon, it's cheap
compared to say, Europe
and other places.
The truth is it's the same
thing with programmers.
Why did programmers program the
way they did in the past
10, 20 years?
Because cycles were cheap.
They knew Moore's law was going
to keep going and so you
could implement some algorithm,
you didn't have to
worry about the details, as
long as you got the right
power law-- if you got your n
squared or n cubed or n log n,
whatever behavior.
The details, if the multiplying
factor was 10 or
100 it didn't matter.
Eventually Moore's law would
solve that problem for you, so
you didn't have to
be efficient.
And I think I've spent the
better part of three years
trying to fight against that and
you're going to learn in
this class that, particularly
for multicore you have to
think very hard about how
you're going to get
performance.
This is actually the take home
message that I want to give.
I think it's just one or two
slides, but we really need to
get to these because that's
where I want to get you
thinking along the
right lines.
And then there's a hardware
consideration, we can skip that.
All right, so where have all
the gigahertz gone, right?
We saw Moore's law, things
getting faster and faster and
the answer is I have a different
chart that's
basically the same thing.
You have relative device
performance on this axis and
you've got the year here.
And different technologies
were growing, growing,
growing, but now you see
they're thresholding.
And you go to conferences now,
architecture conferences, and
people are saying, Moore's
law is dead.
Now, I don't know if I would go
that far and I know there
are true believers out there
who say, well maybe the
silicon on the insulator
technology is dead, but
they'll be something else.
And maybe that's true and maybe
that is multicore, but
unless we get the right
programming models in place
it's not going to
be multicore.
Here's this power
density graph.
Here we have the nuclear reactor
power up here and you
see pentiums going up now.
Of course, there's a log plot,
so we're far away, but on this
axis we're not far away.
This is how much we shrink the
technology, the size of those
transistors.
So if we're kind of going down
by 2 every 18 months or so,
maybe it's 2 years now, we're
not so far away from that
nuclear reactor output.
And that's a problem.
And what's really causing
that problem?
Here's a picture of one of these
gates magnified a lot
and here's the interface
magnified even further and you
see here's this dielectric
that's insulating between the
2 sides of the gate--
we're reaching a fundamental
limit.
A few atomic layers.
You see here it's like 11
angstroms. What's that?
10, 11 atoms across?
If you go back to basic physics
you know that quantum
mechanical properties like
electrons, they tunnel, right?
And they tunnel through barriers
with kind of an
exponential decay.
So whenever you shrink this
further you get more and more
leakage, so the current
is leaking through.
In this graph, what you see here
is that as this size gets
smaller, the leakage current is
getting equivalent to the
active power.
So even when it's not doing
anything, this 65 nanometer,
the technology is leaking
as much power
as it actually uses.
And eventually, as we get
smaller, smaller we're going
to be using more power, just
leaking stuff away and that's
really bad because as Saman
suggested we have people like
Google putting this stuff near
the Coulee Dam so that they
can get power.
I deal with a lot of customers
who have tens of thousands of
nodes, 50,000 processors,
100,000 processors.
They're using 20 gigabytes--
sorry, megahertz.
No, megawatts, that's
what I want to say.
It's too early in the morning.
Tens of megawatts to power
their installations and
they're choosing sites
specifically to get that power
and they're limited.
So they come to me, they come to
people at IBM and they say,
what can we do about power?
Power is a problem.
And that's why we're not seeing
increasing the gigahertz.
Has this ever happened before?
Well, I'm going to go to
this quickly, yes.
Here we see the power outage
output of a steam iron, right
there per unit area.
And something's messed
up here.
You see as the technology
changed from bipolar to CMOS
we were able to improve the
performance, but the heat flux
got higher again and that begs
the question, what's going to
happen next?
And of course, IBM, Intel,
AMD, they're all
betting this multicore.
And so there's an opportunity
from a business point of view.
So now, that's the intro.
Multicore: how do you
deal with it?
Here's a picture of the chip,
the cell processor.
You can see these 8
little black dots.
They're local memory for each
one of 8 special purpose
processors, as well as a big
chunk over here, which is a
ninth processor.
So this chip has 9 processors
on board and the trick is to
design it so that it addresses
lots of issues
that we just discussed.
So let me put this in context,
cell was created for the Sony
Playstation 3.
It started in about 2000 and
there's a long development
here until it was finally
announced over here.
Where was it first announced?
It was announced several years
later and IBM recently
announced a cell blade about a
year back and we're pushing
these blades and we're very
much struggling with the
programming model.
How do you get performance
while making something
programmable?
If you go to customers and they
have 4 million lines of
code, you can't tell them just
port it and it'll be 80 person
years to get it ported,
100 person years more.
And then you have
to optimize it.
So there are problems and
we'll talk about that.
But it was created in this
context and because of that,
this chip in particular, is
a commodity processor.
Meaning that it's going to be
selling millions and millions.
Sony Playstation 2 sold an
average of 20 million units
each year for 5 years and we
expect the same for the
Playstation 3.
So the cell has a big advantage
over other multicore
processors like the Intel
Woodcrest, which has a street
price of about $2000 and
the cell around 100.
So not only do we have big
performance improvements, we
have price advantages
too because of
that commodity market.
All right, let's talk about
the design concept.
Here's a little bit of a rehash
of what we discussed
with some interesting
words here.
We're talking about a power
wall, a memory wall and a
frequency wall.
So we've talked about
this frequency wall.
We're hitting this wall because
of the power really
and the power wall people just
don't have enough power coming
into their buildings to keep
these things going.
But memory wall, Saman didn't
actually use that term, but
that's the fact that as the
clock frequencies get higher
and higher, memory appeared
further and further away.
The more cycles that I have to
go as a processor before the
data came in.
And so that changes the whole
paradigm, how you have to
think about it.
We have processors with lots of
cache, but is cache really
what you want?
Well, it depends.
If you have a very localized
process where you're going to
bring something into cache and
the data is going to be reused
then that's really a
good thing to do.
But what if you have random
gather and scatter of data?
You know, you're doing some
transactional processing or
whatever mathematical function
you're calculating is very
distributed like an FFT.
So you have to do all sorts of
accesses through memory and it
doesn't fit in that cache.
Well, then you can start
thrashing cache.
You bring in one integer and
then you ask the cache for the
next thing, it's not there, so
it has to go in and so you
spend all this time wasting time
getting stuff into cache.
So what we're pushing for
multicore, especially for cell
is the notion of a shopping
list. And this is where
programability comes in and
programing models come in.
You really need to think ahead
of time about what your
shopping list is going to be
and the analogy that people
have been using is you're
fixing something in your
house, you're pipe breaks.
So you go and say, oh,
I need a new pipe.
So you go the store,
you get a pipe.
You bring it back and say,
oh, I need some putty.
So you go to the store,
you get some putty.
And oh, I need a wrench.
Go to the store-- that's
what cache is.
So you figure out what you
need when you need it.
In the cell processor you have
to think ahead and make a
shopping list. If I'm going to
do this calculation I need all
these things.
I'm going to bring them all
in, I'm going to start
calculating.
When I'm calculating on that,
I'm going to get my other
shopping list. So that I can
have some concurrency of the
data load with the computes.
I'm going to skip this here.
You can read that later, it's
not that important.
Cell synergy, now this is kind
of you know, apple pie,
motherhood kind of thing.
The cell processor was
specifically designed so that
those 9 cores are synergistic.
That they interoperate
very efficiently.
Now I told you we have 8
identical processors, we call
those SPEs.
In the ninth processor
its the PPE.
It's been designed so that the
PPE is running the OS and it's
doing all the transaction file
systems and what not so that
these SPEs can focus on
what they're good
at, which is compute.
The whole thing is pullled
together with an element
interconnect bus and we'll
talk about that.
It's very, very efficient,
very high bandwidth bus.
Now we're going to talk about
the detail hardware
components.
And Rodric somewhere, there you
are, asked me to actually
dig down into more
of the hardware.
I would love to do that.
Honestly, I'm not a
hardware person.
I'll do the best I can, perhaps
at the end of the talk
we'll dig down and show me
which slides you want.
But I've been dealing with this
for so long that I can do
a decent job.
Here's another picture
of the chip.
It has lots of transistors.
This is the size.
We talked about the 9 cores, it
has 10 threads because this
power processor, the
PPE has 2 threads.
Each of these are
single threaded.
And this is the wow factor.
We have 200 gigaflops, over
200 gigaflops of single
precision performance
on these chips.
And over 20 gigaflops of double
precision and that will
be going up to 100 gigaflops
by the end of this year.
The bandwidth to main memory is
25 gigabytes per second and
up to 75 gigabytes per second
of I/O bandwidth.
Now this chip really has
tremendous bandwidth, but what
we've seen so far-- particularly
with the Sony
Playstation and I think you may
have lots of them here,
the board is not designed
to really take
advantage of that bandwidth.
And even the blades that IBM
sells really can't get that
type of bandwidth
off the blade.
And so if you're keeping
everything local on the blade
or on the Playstation 3 then
you have lots of bandwidth
internally.
But off blade or off board you
really have to survive with
something like a gigabyte, 2
gigabytes in the future.
And this element interconnect
bus I mentioned before has a
tremendous bandwidth, over
300 gigabytes per second.
The top frequency in the lab
was over 4 gigabytes--
gigahertz, sorry.
And it's currently
running when you
buy them at 3.2 gigahertz.
And actually the Playstation 3's
that you're buying today,
I think, they only use
7 out of the 8 SPEs.
And that was a design
consideration from the
hardware point of view because
as these chips get bigger and
bigger, which is if you can't
ratchet up the gigahertz you
have to spread out.
And so as they get bigger, flaws
in the manufacturing
process lead to faulty units.
So instead of just throwing away
things, if one of these
SPE is bad we don't use
it and we just do 7.
As the design process gets
better by the end of this year
they'll be using 8.
The blades that IBM sells,
they're all set up for 8
OK, so here's a schematic view
of what you just saw on the
previous slide.
You have these 8 SPEs.
You have the PPE here with
this L1 and L2 cache.
You have the element
interconnect bus connecting
all of these pieces together
to a memory interface
controller and a bus interface
controller.
And so this MIC is what has the
25.6 gigabytes per second
and this BIC has potentially
75 going out here.
Each of these SPEs has
its own local store.
Those are those little black
dots that you saw, those 8
black dots.
It's not very large, it's a
quarter of a megabyte, but
it's very fast to this SXU,
this processing unit.
It's only 6 cycles away
from that unit.
And it's a fully pipelined 6
so that if you feed that
pipeline you can get
data every cycle.
And here, the thing that you
can't read because it's
probably too dark is
the DMA engine.
So one of the interesting things
about this is that each
one of these is a full
fledged processor.
It can access main memory
independent of this PPE.
So you can have 9 processes or
10 if you're running 2 threads
here, all going simultaneously,
all
independent of one another.
And that allows for a
tremendous amount of
flexibility in the types of
algorithms you can implement.
And because of this bus here you
can see it's 96 bytes per
cycle and we're at
3.2 gigahertz.
I think that's 288 gigabytes
per second.
These guys can communicate to
one another across this bus
without ever going out to main
memory and so they can get
much faster access to their
local memories.
So if you're doing lots of
computes internally here you
can scream on this processing;
really, really go fast. And
you can do the same if you're
going out to the memory
interface controller here
to main memory, if you
sufficiently hide that
memory access.
So we'll talk about that.
All right, this is the PPE
that I mentioned before.
It's based on the IBM power
family of processors, it's a
watered down version to reduce
the power consumption.
So it doesn't have the horse
power that you see in say a
Pentium 4 or even--
actually, I don't have an exact
comparison point for
this processor, but if you take
the code that runs today
on your Intel or AMD, whatever
your power and you recompile
it on cell it'll run today--
maybe you have to change the
library or two, but it'll run
today here, no problem.
But it'll be about 60% slower,
50% slower and so people say,
oh my god this cell processor's
terrible.
But that's because you're only
using that one piece.
So let's look at the other--
OK, so now we go into
details of the PPE.
Half a megabyte of L2 cache
here, coherent load stores.
It does have a VMX unit,
so you can do some SIMD
operations, single instruction
multiple data instructions.
Two-way hardware multithreaded
here.
Then there's an EIB that
goes around here.
It's composed of four
16 byte data rings.
And you can have multiple,
simultaneous transfers per
ring for a total of over 100
outstanding requests
simultaneously.
But this slide doesn't--
this kind of hides
it under the rug.
There's a certain
topology here.
And so these things
are going to be
connected to those 8 SPEs.
And depending on which way you
send things, you'll have
better or worse performance.
So some of these buses are going
around this way and some
are going counterclockwise.
And because of that you have
to know who you're
communicating if you want have
real high efficiency.
I haven't seen personally cases
where it made a really
big difference, but I do know
that there's some people who
found, if I'm going from here
to here I want to make sure
I'm sending things the right
way because of that
connectivity.
Or else I could be sending
things all the
way around and waiting.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question.
MICHAEL PERRONE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just like you said you
could complie anything on
the power processor would
be slower, but you can.
Now you also said the cell
processor is in itself a
[INAUDIBLE] processor.
Can I compile it in a C code
just for that as well.
MICHAEL PERRONE: C code
would compile.
There's issues with libraries
because the libraries wouldn't
be ported to the SPE
necessarily.
If it had been then yes.
This is actually a very
good question.
It opens up lots of things.
I don't know if I should
take that later.
PROFESSOR: Take it later.
MICHAEL PERRONE: Bottom line is
this chip has two different
processors and therefore you
need two different compilers
and it generates two different
source codes.
In principle, SPEs can run a
full OS, but they're not
designed to do that and no one's
ever actually tried.
So you could imagine having 8
or 9 OSes running on this
processor if you wanted.
Terrible waste from my
perspective, but OK, so let's
talk about these a little bit.
Each of these SPEs has, like I
mentioned this memory flow
controller here, an atomic
update unit, the local store,
and the SPU, which is actually
the processing unit.
Each SPU has a register file
with 128 registers.
Each register is 128 bits.
So they're native SIMD, there
are no scalar registers here
for the user to play with.
If you want to do scalar ops
they'll be running in those
full vector registers, but
you'll just be wasting some
portion of that register.
It has IEEE double precision
floating point, but it doesn't
have IEEE single precision
floating point.
It's curiosity, but that was
again, came from the history.
The processor was designed for
the gaming industry and the
gamers, they didn't care
if it had IEEE.
Who cares IEEE?
What I want is to have good
monsters right on the screen.
And so those SIMD registers can
operate bitwise on bytes,
on shorts, on four words at a
time or two doubles at a time.
The DMA engines here, each DMA
engine can have up to 16
outstanding requests in its
queue before it stalls.
So you can imagine you're
writing something, some code
and you're sending things out
to the DMA and then all of a
sudden you see really bad
performance, it could be that
your DMA egine has stalled
the entire processor.
If you try to write to that
thing and then that queue is
full, it just waits until the
next open slot is available.
So those are kind
considerations.
AUDIENCE: You mean
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's not
the global one?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Right.
That's correct.
But there is a global
address space.
AUDIENCE: 16 slots
each in each SPU.
MICHAEL PERRONE: Right.
Exactly.
Each MFC has its own 16 slots.
And they all address
the same memory.
They can have a transparent
memory space or they can have
a partitioned memory
space depending on
how you set it up.
AUDIENCE: Each SPU doesn't have
its own-- the DMA goes
onto the bus, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that goes to a connection
to the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You can add this
data in the SPUs too.
You don't have to always
go to outside memory.
You can do SPU to SPU
communication basically.
MICHAEL PERRONE: Right.
So I can do a DMA that transfers
memory from this
local store to this one if I
wanted to and vice versa.
And I can pull stuff
in through the--
yeah, I mentioned this stuff.
Now this broadband interface
controller, the BIC, this is
how you get off the blade
or off the board.
It has 20 gigabytes per
second here on I/O IF.
In 10 over here--I'm
sorry, 5 over here.
I'm trying to remember
how we get up to 70.
This is actually two-way
and one is 25 and
the other one's 30.
That gets you to 55.
This should be 10 and now,
what's going on here?
It adds up to 75, I'm sure.
I'm sure about that.
I don't know why
that says that.
But the interesting thing about
this over here, this I/O
IF zero is that you can
use it to connect two
cell processors together.
So this is why I know it's
really 25.6 because it's
matched to this one.
So you have 25.6 going out to
main memory, but this one can
go to another processor, so
now you have these two
processors side-by-side
connected at 25.6 gigabytes
per second.
And now I can do a memory access
through here to the
memory that's on this processor
and vice versa.
However, If I'm going straight
out to my memory it's going to
be faster than if I go
out to this memory.
So you have a slight NUMA
architecture and nonuniform
memory access.
And you can hide that with
sufficient multibuffering.
So I know that this is 25 and
I know the other one's 30.
I don't know why it's
written as 20 there.
AUDIENCE: Can the SPUs
write to the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Yes, they
can read from it.
I don't know if they
can write to it.
In fact, that leads to a
bottleneck occurring.
So I happily start a process on
my PPE and then I tell all
my SPEs, start doing some
number crunching.
So they do that.
They get access to memory, but
they find the memory is in L2.
So they start pulling from L2,
but now all 8 are pulling from
L2 and it's only 7 gigabytes per
second instead of 25 and
so you get a bottleneck.
And so what I tell everybody
is if you're going to
initialize data with that PPE
make sure you flush your cache
before you start the SPEs.
And then you don't want to be
touching that memory because
you really want to keep things--
stuff that the SPEs
are dealing with-- you want to
keep it out of L2 cache.
Here there's an interrupt
controller.
An I/O bus master translation
unit.
And you know, these allow for
messaging and message passing
and interrupts and things
of that nature.
So that's the hardware
overview.
Any questions before
I move on?
So why's the cell processor
so fast?
Well, 3.2 gigahertz,
that's one.
But there's also the fact
that we have 8 SPEs.
Each 8 SPEs have SIMD units,
registers that are running so
they can do this parallel
processing on a chip.
We have 8 SPEs and each one
are doing up to 8 ops per
cycle if you're doing
a mul-add.
So you have four mul-adds
for single precision.
So you've got 8, that's 64
ops per cycle times 3.2.
You get up to 200 gigaflops
per cycle, 204.8.
So that's really the
main reason.
We've talked about
this stuff here.
This is an image of
why it's faster.
Instead of staging and bringing
the data through the
L2, which is kind of what we
were just discussing and
having this PU, this processing
unit, the PPE
manage the data coming in, each
one can do it themselves
and bypass this bottleneck.
So that's something you have
to keep in the back of your
mind when you're programming.
You really want to make sure
that you get this processor
out of there.
You don't want it in your way.
Let these guys do as much of
their own work as they can.
Here's a comparison of
theorectical peak performance
of cell versus freescale,
AMD, Intel over here.
Very nice.
That's the wow chart.
The theoretical peak, this is in
practice, what did we see?
I don't know if you can read
these numbers but what you
really want to focus on is the
first and last columns.
This is the type of calculation,
high performance
computing like matrix
multiplication,
bioinformatics, graphics,
security, it was really
designed for graphics.
Security, communication, video
processing and over here you
see the advantage against an
IA 32, a G5 processor.
And you see 8x, 12x,
15, 10, 18x.
Very considerable improvement
in performance.
In the back-- question?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
previous slide, how did it
compare to high
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]?
MICHAEL PERRONE: All right, so
you're thinking like a peak
stream or something like that?
AUDIENCE: Any particular
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
The design of the SPUs is
very reminiscent of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
MICHAEL PERRONE: So I believe,
and I'm not well versed in all
of the processors that
are out there.
I think that we still
have a performance
advantage in that space.
You know, I don't know
about Xilinx and
those kind of things--
FPGAs I don't know, but what
I tell people this
is there's a spectrum.
And at one end you have your
general purpose processors.
You've got your Intel, you've
got your Opteron whatever,
your power processor.
And then at the other and you've
got your FPGAs and DSPs
and then maybe over here,
somewhere in the middle you've
got graphical processing
units.
Like Nvidia kind of things.
And then somewhere between
those graphics processing
processors and the
general purpose
processors you've got cell.
You get a significant
improvement in performance,
but you have to pay some
pain in programming.
But not nearly as much as you
have to do with the graphics
processors and no where near
the FPGAs, which are just
every time you write something
you have to rewrite
everything.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Somewhat related to
the previous question, but
with a different angle.
I always figured anyone could
do a [INAUDIBLE], so that's
why I ask about FFTs.
Are they captured on the front
or otherwise [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: Yeah, so this
is actually one of the things
I spent a lot of time
on for FFTs.
I spent a lot of time with
the petroleum industry.
They take these enormous boats,
they have these arrays
that go 5 kilometers back and
1 kilometer wide, they drag
them over the ocean, and they
make these noises and they
record the echo.
And they have to do this
enormous FFT and it
takes them 6 months.
Depending on the size of the FFT
it can be anywhere from a
week to 6 months, literally.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MICHAEL PERRONE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is this a PD FFT?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Sometimes I
do too, but they do both.
I've become somewhat of an
expert on these FFTs.
For cell the best performance
number I know of is about 90
gigaflops of FFT performance.
You know, that's very good.
Yeah, it's like 50% of
peak performance.
You know, it's easy to get
98% with [? lynpacker ?]
or [? djem ?]
on a processor like this and
we have. We get 97% of peak
performance, but it's a lot
harder to get FFTs up to that.
AUDIENCE: Well, then I'll
[INAUDIBLE] the next questions
then which is somehow or
another you get the FFT
performance, you've got to
get the data at the right
place at the time.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So you've personally done that
or been involved with that?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Right, so
we do a lot of tricks.
I can show you another slide or
another presentation that
we talk about this, but
typically the FFTs that we
work with are somewhere from a
1024 to 2048, that's square.
And so it's possible to take
say, the top 4 rows--
in the case of 1024, four rows
complex, single precision I
think is 16 kilobytes.
That fits into the local
store very nicely.
So you can stop multibuffering.
You bring in one, you start
computing on it.
While you're computing on those
4 in a SIMD fashion
across the SIMD registers
you're
bringing in the next one.
And then when that one's
finished you're writing that
one out while your computing
on the one that arrived and
while you're getting
the next one.
And since you can get the entire
1024 or 2000 into local
store, you're only 6 cycles away
from any element in it.
So it's much, much faster.
We also did the 16 million
element FFT.
1D, yeah and we did some
tricks there to make it
efficient, but it was
a lot slower.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
would have to be a lot slower
by the need for the problem.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: What I remember
it was fifteen times
faster than a power 5.
It might have been a power 4,
I don't remember, sorry.
I might want to skip this one.
I think I'm going to
skip this one.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: Right.
Let's talk about what is
the cell good for.
You kind of have a sense of the
architecture and how it
all fits together.
You may have some sense of the
gotchas and the problems that
might be there, but what did
we actually applied to 2?
I mean you saw some
of that here.
Here's a list of things that
either we've already proven to
ourself that it works well or
we're very confident that it
works well or we're working
to demonstrate
that it works well.
Signal processing, image
processing, audio resampling,
noise generation.
I mean, you can read through
this list, there's a long
list. And I guess there are
a few characteristics that
really make it suitable
for cell.
Things that are in single
precision because you've got
200 gigaflops single and only
20 of double, but that will
change as I mentioned.
Things that are streaming,
streaming through and so
single processing is ideal where
the data comes through
and you do your compute and then
you throw it away or you
give out your results and
you throw it away.
Those are good.
And things that are compute
intensive, where you bring the
data in and you're going to
crunch on it for a long time,
so things like cryptography
where you're either generating
something from a key and there's
virtually no input.
You're just generating streams
of random numbers that's very
well suited for this thing.
You see FFTs listed here.
TCPIP off load.
I didn't put that there.
There's actually a problem with
cell today that we're
working to fix that the TCPIP
performance is not very good.
And so what I tell people
to use is open NPI.
You know, so that
over InfiniBand.
The PPE processor really doesn't
have the horse power
to drive a full TCPIP sack.
I'm not sure it has the horse
power to do a full NPI stack
either, but at least you have
more control in that case.
The game physics, physical
simulations--
I can show you a demo, but I
don't know that we'll have
time where a company called
Rapid Mind, which is
developing software to ease
programmability for cell.
Basically you take your existing
scalar code and you
instrument it with C++ classes
that are kind of SPE aware.
And by doing that, just write
your scalar code and you get
the SPE performance advantage.
They have this wonderful
demo of these chickens.
They've got 16,000 chickens
in a chicken yard.
You know, the chicken yard has
varying topologies and the
chickens move around and all
16,000 are being processed in
real time with a single
cell processor.
In fact, the Nvidia card that
was used to render that
couldn't keep up with what was
coming out of the SPEs.
We we're impressed with that.
We're happy with that.
We showed it around at the
game conferences and the
gamers saw all these chickens
and were like,
this is really cool.
How do I shoot them?
So we said, you can't.
But maybe in the next version.
But the idea that we've designed
this so that it can
do physical simulations, and
this is maybe an entree for
some of you people when you're
doing your stuff.
I don't know what kinds of
things you want to try to do
on cell, but I've seen people do
lots of things that really
have no business doing
well on cell and they
did very, very well.
Like pointer chasing.
I'm trying to remember.
There are two pieces of work.
One done by PNNL Fabritzio
Petrini and he did a graph
traversal algorithm.
It was very much random access
and he was able to parallelize
that very nicely on Cell.
And then there was another guy
at Georgia Tech who did
something similar for
linked lists.
And you know, I expect things
to work well on cell if
they're streaming and they have
very compute intensive
kernels that are working on
things, but those are two
examples where they're very not
very compute intensive and
not very streaming.
They're kind of random access
and they work very well.
Over here, target
applications.
There are lots of areas
where we're trying
to push cell forward.
Clearly it works in the
gaming industry, but
where else can it work?
So medical imaging, there's
a lot of success there.
The sysmic imaging for
petroleum, aerospace and
defense for radar and sonar--
these are all signal
processing apps.
We're also looking at digital
content creation
for computer animation.
Very well suited for cell.
This is kind just what
I just said.
Did I leave out anything?
Finance-- once we have double
precision we'll be doing
things with finance.
We actually demonstrated that
things work very well.
You know, metropolis algorithms,
Monte Carlo, Black
shoals algorithms if you're
familiar with these kind of
things from finance.
They tell us they need double
precision and we're like, you
don't really need double
precision, come on.
I mean, what you have is some
mathematical calculation that
you're doing and you're doing
it over and over and over.
And Monte Carlo there's so much
noise, we say to these
people, why do you need
double precision?
It turns out with decimal
notation you can only go up to
like a billion or something
in single precision.
So they have more dollars than
that, so they need double, for
that reason alone.
But this gets back to the
sloppiness of programmers.
And I'm guilty of this myself.
They said, oh we have double.
Let's use double.
They didn't need to, but
they did it anyway.
And now their legacy code
is stuck with double.
They could convert it all to
single, but it's too painful.
Down on Wall Street to build a
new data center is like $100
million proposition.
And they do it regularly,
all of the banks.
They'll be generating a new
data center every year,
sometimes multiple times a year
and they just don't have
time or the resources to go
through and redo all their
code to make it run or
something like cell.
So we're making double
precision cell.
That's the short of it.
All right, now software
environment.
This is stuff that you can find
on the web and actually,
it's changing a lot lately
because we just
released the 2.0 SDK.
And so the stuff that's in the
slide might not actually be
the latest and greatest, but
it's going to be epsilon away,
so don't worry about
it too much.
But you really shouldn't trust
these slides, you should go to
the website and the website
you want to go to is
www.ibm.com/alphaworks.
PROFESSOR: Tomorrow we are going
to have a recitation
session talking about
the environment
that we have created.
I think we just got, probably
just set up the latest
environment and then we increase
it through the three
weeks we've got.
This is changing faster than
a three week cycle.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
So this will give you a preview
of what's going to be.
MICHAEL PERRONE: Then you go
to alphaworks, you go to
search on alphaworks for cell
and you get more information
then you could ever
possibly read.
We have a programmer's manual
that's 900 pages long, it's
really good reading.
Actually there's one thing in
that 800, 900 hundred pages
that you really should read.
It's called the cell programming
tips chapter.
It's a really nice chapter.
But there are many, many
publications and things like
that, more than just the SDK
in the OS and whatnot, so I
encourage you to look at that.
All right, so this is kind
of the pyramid, the
cell software pyramid.
We've got the standards under
here, the application binary
interface, language
extensions.
And over here we have
development tools and we'll
talk about each of these
pieces briefly.
These specifications define
what's actually the reference
implementation for the cell.
C++ and C, they have language
extensions in the similar way
to the extensions for VMX
for SSE on Intel.
You have C extensions for cell
that allow you to use
intrinsics that actually run as
SIMD instructions on cell.
For example, you can say SPU
underscore mul-add, and it's
going to do a vector mul-add.
So you can get assembly language
level control over
your code without having to
use any assembly language.
And then there's that.
There is a full system
simulator.
The simulator is very, very
accurate for things that do
not run out to main memory.
They've been working to improve
this so I don't know
if recently they have made it
more accurate, but if you're
doing compute intensive stuff,
if you're compute bound the
simulator can give you
accuracies within 99%.
You know, within 1%
of the real value.
I've only seen one thing on the
simulator more than 1% off
and that was 4%, so the
simulator is very-- excuse
me-- very reliable.
And I encourage you to
use it if you can't
get access to hardware.
What else?
The simulator has all kinds
of tools in there.
And I'm not going to go through
the software stack in
simulation.
This gives you a sense for--
you've got your hardware
running here.
You can run this on any one of
these platforms. Power PC,
Intel with these OS's.
The whole thing is written
in TCL, the simulator.
And it has all these
kind of simulators.
It's simulating the DMAs, it's
simulating the caches and then
you get a graphical user
interface and a command line
interface to that simulator.
THe graphical user interface is
convenient, but the command
line gives you much
more control.
You can treat parameters.
This gives you a view of
what the graphical
userface looks like.
It says mambo zebra because that
was a different project,
but now it'd probably
say system sim or
something like that.
And you'll see the PPC--
this is the PPE I don't know
why they changed it.
And then you have SP of zero,
SP of 1 going down and it
gives you some access
to these parameters.
The model here, it says pipeline
and then there's I
think, functional mode
or pipeline mode.
Pipeline mode is where it's
really simulating everything
and it's much slower.
But it's accurate.
And then the other is functional
mode just to test
the code actually works
as it's supposed to.
PROFESSOR: I guess one point
in the class what we'll try
and do is since each group has
access to the the hardware,
you can do most of the things
in the real hardware and use
the debugger in the
hardware that's
probably been talked about.
But if things gets really bad
and you can't understand use
simulator as a very accurate
debugger only when it's needs
needed because there you
can look at every
little detail inside.
This is kind of a thing, a
last resort type thing.
MICHAEL PERRONE:
Yeah, I agree.
Like I said, I've been doing
this for three years.
Three years ago we didn't
even have hardware.
So the simulator was all we had,
so we relied on it a lot.
But I think that usage of
it makes a lot of sense.
This is the graphical
interface.
You know, it's just a
Tickle interface.
I'm going to skip through
these things.
It just shows you how you can
look at memory with this more
memory access.
You get some graphical
representation of various pieces.
You know, how many stalls?
How many loads?
How many DMA transactions?
So you can see what's going
on at that level.
And all of this can be
pulled together into
this UART window here.
OK, so the Linux, it's pretty
standard Linux, but it has
some extensions.
Let's see.
Provided as a patch, yeah.
That might be wrong.
I don't know where
we are currently.
You have this SPE thread
API for creating
threads from the PPEs.
Let's see.
What do I want to
tell you here?
There's a better slide for
this kind of information.
They share the memory space,
we talked about that.
There's error event and
signal handling.
So there are multiple ways
you communicate.
You can communicate with the
interrupts and the event and
signaling that way or you
can use these mailboxes.
So each SPE has its own mailbox
and inbox and an
outbox so you can post something
to your outbox and
then the PPE will read
it when it's ready.
Or you can read from your inbox
waiting on the PPE to
write something.
You have to be careful because
you can stall there.
If the PPE hasn't written you
will stall waiting for
something to fill up.
So you can do a check.
There are ways to get around
that, but these are kind of
common gotchas that you
have to watch out for.
Then you have the mailboxes, you
have the interrupts, you
also have DMAs.
You can do communication with
DMAs so you have at least
three different ways that
you communicate
between the SPEs on cell.
And which one is going to be
best really depends on the
algorithm you're running.
So these are the extensions
to Linux.
This is going to show you a
bunch of things that you
probably won't be able to read,
but there's something
called SPUFS, the file system
that has a bunch of open,
read, write, and close
functionality.
And then we also have this
signaling and the mailboxes
that I mentioned to
you previously.
And this you can't even read.
I can't even read this one.
What is it?
Ah, this is perhaps the
most important one.
It says SPU create thread.
So the SPEs from the Linux point
of view are just threads
that are running.
The Linux doesn't really know
that they're special purpose
hardware, it just knows it's a
thread and you can do things
like spawn a thread, kill a
thread, wait on a thread-- all
the usual things that you
can do with threads.
So it's a lot like P
threads, but it's
not actually P threads.
So here you could see these
things are more useful.
This is SPE create groups.
So you can create a thread and
thread group so that threads
that are part of the same group
know about one another.
So you can partition your system
and have three SPEs
doing one thing and five
doing another.
So that you can split it
up however you like.
You have get and set affinity
so that you can choose which
SPEs are running which tasks,
so that you can get more
efficient use of that element
interconnect bus.
Kill and waits, open, close,
writing signals, the usual.
Let me check my time here.
I really don't have a lot more
time, so I'm going to say that
we have this thread management
library.
It has the functionality
that I just mentioned.
In the next month or so you're
going to go through that in a
lot more detail.
The SPE comes with a lot
of sample libraries.
These are not necessarily the
very best implementation of
these libraries and they're
not even fully functional
libraries, but they're
suggestive of first of all,
how things can be written to
cell, how to use cell, and in
some cases how to
optimize cell.
Like the basic matrix
operations, there's some
optimization.
The FFTs are very tightly
optimized, so if you want to
take a look at that and
understand how to do that type
of memory manipulation.
So there are samples codes out
there that can be very useful.
We'll skip that.
Oh, this is that
FFT 16 million.
There's an example,
it's on the SDK.
Actually, I don't know if you've
got PS3's if all these
things can run.
They should run.
Yeah, they should run.
There may be some memory issues
out to main memory that
I'm not aware of.
There are all kinds of demos
there that you can play with,
which are good for learning
how to spawn threads and
things like that.
You have your basic GNU
binutils tools.
There's GCC out there.
There's also XLC.
You can download XLC.
In some cases, one will be
better than the other, but I
think in most cases XLC's
a little better.
Or in some cases, actually
a lot better.
So you can get that.
I'd recommend that.
There's a debugger which
provides application source
level debugging.
PPE multithreading, SPE
multithreading, the
interaction between
these guys.
There are three modes for the
debugger: stand alone and then
attached to SPE threads.
Sounds like two.
That's problematic.
There's this nice static
analysis tool.
This is good for looking
for really tightly,
optimizing your code.
You have to be able to read
assembly, but it shows you
graphically--
kind of--
where the stalls are happening
and you can try and
reorganize your code.
And then like Saman suggested,
the dynamic analysis using the
simulator is a good way to
really get cycle by cycle
stepping through the code.
And someone was very excited
when they made this chart
because they put these
big explosions here.
You've got some compiler here
that's going to be generating
two pieces of code, the PPE
binary and the SPE binary.
When you go through the cell
tutorials for training on how
to program cell you'll see that
this code is actually
plugged into-- linked
into the PPE code.
And when the PPE code spawns a
thread it's going to take a
pointer to this code and
basically DMA that code into
the SPE and tell the SPE
to start running.
Once it's done that, that
thread is independent.
The PPE could kill it, but it
could just let it run to its
natural termination or this
thing could terminate itself
or it could be interrupted by
some other communication.
But that's the basic process,
you have these
two pieces of code.
OK, so now this is really
what I wanted to get to.
So I want lots of
questions here.
There are 4 levels of
parallelism in cell.
On the cell blade, the IBM
blade you have two cell
processors per blade.
So that's one level
of parallelism.
At chip level we know there are
9 cores and they're all
running independently.
That's another level
of parallelism.
On the instruction level each
of the SPEs has two
instruction pipelines, so it's
an odd and an even pipeline.
One pipeline is doing things--
the odd pipeline is doing
loads and stores, DMA
transactions, interrupts,
branches and it's doing
something called shuffle byte
or the shuffle operation.
So shuffle operation's a very,
very useful operation that
allows you to take two registers
as data, a third
register as a pattern register,
and the fourth
register as output.
It then, from this pattern, will
choose arbitrarily the
bytes that are in these two
and reconstitute them into
this fourth register.
It's wonderful for doing
manipulations and shuffling
things around.
Like shuffling a deck of cards,
you could take all of
these and ignore this or you
could take the first one here,
replicate it 16 times or you
could take a random sampling
from these, put into
that register.
AUDIENCE: Do you use that
specifically for the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
MICHAEL PERRONE: We
do use it, yeah.
Yeah, you take a look, you'll
see we use shuffle a lot.
It's surprising how valuable
shuffle can be.
However, then you have to worry
now, you've got the
shuffle here, if you're doing
like matrix transpose, it's
all shuffles.
But what's a date matrix
transpose?
It's really bandwidth
bound, right?
Because you're pulling data in,
shuffling it around and
sending it out.
Well, where's the reads
and writes?
They're on the odd pipeline.
Where are the shuffles?
So now you can have a situation
where it's all
shuffle, shuffle, shuffle,
shuffle and then the
instruction pre-fetch buffer
gets starved and so it stalls
for 15, 17 cycles while
I have to load.
Basically, it's a tiny
little loop.
But you get stalls and you get
really bad performance.
So then you have to tell
the compiler--
actually, the compiler
is getting
better at these things.
Much better than it used to be
or by hand you can force it to
leave a slot for
the pre-fetch.
These are gotchas
that programmers
have to be aware of.
On the other pipeline you have
all your normal operations.
So you have your mul-adds, your
bit operations, all the
shift and things like that,
they're all over there.
There is one other operation
on the odd pipeline and I
think it's a quad
word rotate or
something, but I don't remember.
So that's instruction level
dual issue parallelism.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: Everything
is in order on
this processor, yeah.
And that was done for power
reasons, right?
Get rid of all the space and all
the transistors that are
doing all this fancy,
out of order
processing to save power.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: That's
a really good point.
When you're doing scalar
processing you think well,
you're thinking I'm going to--
kind of conceptually, you want
to have all the things that
are doing the same thing
together right.
That's how I used to program.
You put all this stuff here
then you do maybe all your
reads or whatever and then you
do all your computes and you
can't do it that way.
You have to really think about
how are you going to interlead
these things.
Now the compiler will help you,
but to get really high
performance you have to have
better tools and we don't have
those tools yet.
And so I'm hoping that you guys
are the ones that are
going to come up with the new
tools, the new ideas that are
going to really help
people improve
programmability in cell.
Then at the lowest level you
have the register level
parallelism where you can have
four single precision float
ops going simultaneously.
So when you're programming cell
you have to keep all of
these levels of hierarchy
in your head.
It's not straight scalar
programming anymore.
And if you think of it that way
you're just not going to
get the performance that you're
looking for period.
Another consideration
is this local store.
Each little store is
256 kilobytes.
That's not a lot of space.
You have to think about how
are you going to bring the
data in so that the chunks are
big enough, but not too big
because if they're too big thing
then you won't be able
to get multibuffering.
Let's back up a little
bit more.
The local store holds the data,
but it also holds the
code that you're running.
So if you have 200 kilobytes of
code then you only have 56
kilobytes of data space.
And if you want to have double
buffering that means you only
have 25 kilobytes and then as
Saman correctly points out
there's a problem with stack.
So if you're going to have
recursion in your code or
something nasty like that,
you're going to start pushing
stack variables off
the register file.
So where do they go?
They go in the local store.
What prevents the stack them
overwriting your data?
Nothing.
Nothing at all and that's
a big gotcha.
I've seen over the past three
years maybe 30 separate
algorithms implemented on cell
and I know of only one that
was definitely doing that.
But you know, if there are 30
in this class maybe you're
going to be the one that
that happens to.
So you have to be aware
of that and you have
to deal with it.
So what you can do, is in the
local store put some dead beef
thing in there so that you can
look for an overwrite and that
will let you know that either
you have to make you code
smalller or your data smaller
or get rid of recursion.
On SPEs, recursion is
kind of anathema.
Inlining is good.
Inlining really can accelerate
your codes performance.
Oh yeah, it says stack
right there.
You're reading ahead
on me here.
Yes, so all three are in
there and you have
to be aware of that.
Now there is a memory management
library, very
lightweight library on the SPE
and it's going to prevent your
data from overwriting your code
because once the code's
loaded that memory management
library knows where it is and
it will stop.
The date you from allocating,
doing a [? mul-add. ?]
over this code.
But the stack's up for grabs.
And that was again done
because of power
considerations and real
estate on the chip.
It you want to have a chip
that's this big you can have
anything you want, but
manufacturing it's impossible.
So things were removed and that
was one of the things
that's removed and that's one
of the things you have to
watch out for.
And communication, we've talked
about this quite a bit.
I didn't mention this: the
DMA transactions-- oh,
question in the back?
AUDIENCE: Is there any
reasonable possibility of
doing things dynamically?
Is it at all conceivable to have
[? bunks ?] that fetch in
new code or an allocator
that shuffles somehow?
Or is it basically as soon as
you get to that point your
performance is going
to go to hell.
MICHAEL PERRONE: Yes, well if
you don't do anything about
it, yes your performance
will go to hell.
So there are two ways.
In research we came up with
an overlay mechanism.
So this is what people used
to do 20 years ago when
processors were simple.
Well, these processors are
simple, so going back to the
old technologies is actually
a good thing to do.
So we had a video processing
algorithm where we took video
images, we had to decode them
with one SPE, we had to do
some background subtraction
to the next SPE.
We had to do some
edge detection.
And so each SPE was doing a
different thing, but even then
the code was very big, the
chunks of code were large.
And we were spending 27% of the
time swapping code out and
bringing in new code.
Bad, very bad.
Oh, and I should tell
you, spawning SPE
threads is very painful.
500,000 cycles, a
million cycles--
I don't know.
It varies depending on how the
SPE feels that particular day.
And it's something to avoid.
You really want to spawn a
thread and keep it running for
a long time.
So context switching
is painful on cell.
Using an overlay we got that
27% overhead down to 1%.
So yes, you can do that.
That tool is not in the SDK.
It's on my to-do list to put
it in the SDK, but the
compiler team at IBM tells
me that the XLC
compiler now does overlays.
But it only does overlays at the
function level, so if the
function still doesn't
fit in the SPE
you're dead in the water.
And I think the compiler will
say, when it compiles it it'll
say this doesn't fit quietly
and you'll never see that
until you run and it doesn't
load and you don't know
what's going on.
So read your compiler outputs.
The DMA granularity
is 128 bytes.
This is the same, the data
transactions for Intel, for
AMD they're all 128 byte
data envelopes.
So if you're doing a memory
access that's 4 bytes you're
still using 128 bytes
of bandwidth.
So this comes back to this
notion of getting a shopping
list. You really want to think
ahead what you want to get,
bring it in, then use it
so that you don't waste
bandwidth; if you're
bandwidth bound.
If you're not than you can be
a little more wasteful.
But there's a guy,
Mike Acton--
you can find his website, I
think he has a website called
www.cellperformance.org?
Net?
Com?
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick comment
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
MICHAEL PERRONE:
Oh, he's good.
He's much better than me.
You're really going
to like him.
His belief, and I believe him
wholeheartedly, is it's all
about the data.
We're coming to a point in
computer science where the
code doesn't matter as much
as getting the data
where you need it.
This is because of the latency
out to main memory.
Memory's getting so far away
that having all these cycles
is not that useful anymore if
you can't get the data.
So he always pushes
this point, you
have to get the data.
You have to think about the
data, good code starts with
the data, good code ends with
the data, good data structure
start with the data.
You have to think data,
data, data.
And I can't emphasize that
enough because it's really
very, very true for this
processor and I believe, for
all the multicore processors
you're going to be seeing.
The DMAs that you issue can be
128 bytes or multiples of 128
bytes, up to 16 kilobytes
per single DMA.
There's also something called a
DMA list, which is a list of
DMAs in local store and you tell
the DMA queue OK, here
are these 100 DMAs,
spawn them off.
That only takes one slot in
the DMA queue so it's an
efficient way of loading
the queue without
overloading the queue.
Traffic controls, this is
perhaps one of the trickier
things with cell because the
simulator doesn't help very
much and the tools don't
help very much.
Thinking about synchronization,
DMA latency
handling-- all those things
are important.
OK, so this is the last slide
that I'm going to do and then
I have to run off.
I want to give you a sense for
the process by which people--
my group in particular went
through, especially when we
didn't even have hardware and we
didn't have compilers that
worked nearly as well as they
do now and it's really very
ugly knifes and stones
and sticks.
You know, just kind
of stone knifes.
That's what I'm thinking,
very primitive.
But this way of thinking is
still very much true.
You have to think about
your code this way.
You want to start, you have your
application, whatever it
happens to be; you
want to do an
algorithmic complexity study.
Is this order n squared,
is this log n?
Where are the bottlenecks?
What do I expect to
be bottlenecks?
Then I want to do data
layout/locality.
Now this is the data, data, data
approach of Mike Acton.
You want to think
about the data.
Where is it?
How can you structure your data
so that it's going to be
efficiently positioned
for when you need it?
And then you start with an
experimental petitioning of
the algorithm.
You want to break it up between
the pieces that you
believe are scalar and remain
scalar, leave those on the SPE
and the ones that can
be paralellized.
Those are the ones that are
going to go on the SPE.
You have the think conceptually
about
partitioning that out.
And then run it on
the PPE anyway.
You want to have a
baseline there.
Then you have this PPE scalar
code and PPE control code.
This PPE scalar code you want to
then push down to the SPEs.
So now you're going to add
stuff for communication,
synchronization, and
latency handling.
So you have the spawn threads.
The [? RAIDs ?]
have to be told where the data
is, they have to get their
code, they have to run their
code, they have to then start
pulling in the data, synchronize
with the other
SPEs and then latency handling
with multibuffering of the
data so that you can be doing
computing and reading data
simultaneously.
Then you have your first
parallel code that's running.
Now the compiler, the XLC
compiler, GCC compiler--
well, the XLC compiler I know
for certain will do some
automatic SIMDization.
if you put the auto
SIMD flag on.
Does GCC compiler do that?
PROFESSOR:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: OK, so I
don't know if the GCC
compiler does that.
So that can be done by hand,
but sometimes that works,
sometimes it doesn't.
And it really depends on how
complex the algorithm.
If it's a very regular code,
like a matrix-matrix multiply.
You'll see that the compiler
can do fairly well if the
block sizes are right and all.
But if you have something that's
more irregular then you
may find that doing it by
hand is really required.
And so this step here could
be done with the compiler
initially to see if you're
getting the performance that
you think you should be getting
from that algorithmic
complexity study.
You should see that
type of scaling.
You can look at the CPI and
see how many cycles per
instruction you're getting.
Each SPE should be
getting 0.5.
You should be able to get two
instructions per cycle.
Very few codes actually
get exactly--
you can get down to 5.8 or
something like that, but I
think if you can get to
1 you're doing well.
If you get to 2 there's probably
more you can be doing
and if you're above 2
there's something
wrong with your code.
It may be the algorithm.
It may be just a poorly
chosen algorithm.
But that's where you
can talk to me.
I want to make myself available
to everyone in the
class or in my department
as well.
We're very enthusiastic about
working with research groups
in universities to develop new
tools, new methods and if you
can help me, I can help you.
I think it works very well.
Then once you've done this,
you may find that what you
originally thought for the
complexity or the layout
wasn't quite accurate, so you
need to then go do some
additional rebalancing.
Maybe change your block sizes.
You know, maybe you had 64 by 64
blocks, now you need 32 by
64 or 48 by whatever-- some
readjustment to match what you
have, And then you may want to
reevaluate the data movement.
And then you know, in many
cases you'll be done, but
you're looking at your cycles
per instruction or your speed
up and you're not seeing exactly
what you expected, so
you can start looking at other
optimization considerations.
Like using the vector unit,
the VMX unit on the cell
processor, on the PPE.
Looking for system bottlenecks
and this is actually, I have
found the biggest problem.
Trying to identify where the DMA
bottlenecks are happening
is kind of devilishly hard.
We don't have good tools for
that, so you really have to
think hard and come up with
interesting kind of
experiments for your code to
track down these bottlenecks.
And then load balancing.
If you look at these SPEs, I
told you they're completely
independent.
You can have them all running
the same code or they could be
running all different code.
They could be daisy chained so
that this one feeds, this one
feeds that one, feeds
that one.
If you do that daisy chaining
you may find out there's a
bottleneck.
That this SPE takes three
times as long
as any of the others.
So make that use 3 SPEs and have
this SPE feed these 3.
So you have to do some load
balancing and thinking about
how many SPEs really need
to be dedicated
to each of the tasks.
Now that's the end of my talk.
I think that gives you a good
sense of where we have been,
where we are now, and
where we're going.
And I hope that if was good,
educational, and I'll make
myself available to you
guys in the future.
And if you have questions--
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
I know you have to
catch a flight.
How much time do have
for questions?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Not much.
I leave at 1:10.
So I should be there by 12:00.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
at some time.
MICHAEL PERRONE:
My car is out--
PROFESSOR: OK, so we'll have
about 5 minutes questions.
OK, so I know this
talk is early.
We haven't gotten a lot of
basics so there might be a lot
of things kind of going above
your head, but we'll slowly
get back to it.
So questions?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that SPEs would
be able to run kernel.
Is there a microkernel that you
could install on them so
that you could begin
experimenting with MPI type
structures?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Not
that I'm aware of.
We did look at something called
MicroMPI, where we were
using kind of a very watered
down MPI implementation for
the SPEs in the transactions.
I don't recommend it.
What I recommend is you have a
cluster say, a thousand node
cluster and the code today,
the legacy code that's out
there runs some process
on this node.
Take that process, don't try to
push MPI further down, but
just try to subpartition that
process and let the PPE handle
all the communication
off board, off node.
That's my recommendation.
AUDIENCE: So MPI is running
on [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
MICHAEL PERRONE:
Yeah, Open MPI.
It's an open source MPI.
It's just a recompile
and it hasn't
been tuned or optimized.
And it doesn't know anything
about the SPEs.
You know, you let the PPE do
all the communication or
handle the communications.
When it finishes the task
at hand then it can
issue its MPI process.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: Open NP is the
methodology where you take
existing scalar code and you
insert compiler pragmas to say
this for loop can
be parallelized.
And you know, this data
structures are disjoint, so we
don't have to worry about any
kind of interference, side
effects of the data
manipulation.
The compiler, the XLC compiler
implements open MP.
There's several components
that are required.
One was a software cache where
they implemented a little
cache on the local store.
And if it misses in that local
cache it goes and gets it.
I don't know how well that
performs yet, but it exists.
There's the SIMDization.
For a while, Open NP wasn't
working with auto SIMDization
but now it does.
So it's getting there,
for so C it's there.
I don't know what type
of performance hit
you take for that.
AUDIENCE: Probably runs
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
MICHAEL PERRONE: It's
XLC version that does that.
I don't know if GCC does it.
But my recommendation is if you
want to use open NP, go
ahead, take your scalar code,
implement it with those
pragmas, see what type of
improvement you get.
Play around with it a little.
If you find something that you
expect should be 10x better
and it's only 3x take
that bottleneck and
implement it by hand.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
with the memory models and such
that the SPEs certainly
went back a couple of
generations to a simpler
[INAUDIBLE].
How come you went so far back
rather to just say,
segmentation.
MICHAEL PERRONE: I don't
know the answer.
I'm sorry.
I suspect and most of these
answers come down to the same
thing, it comes back to Sony.
Sony contracted with IBM,
gave us a lot of money
to make this thing.
And they said we need
a Playstation 3.
We need this, this,
this, this.
And so IBM was very focused
on providing those things.
Now that that is delivered,
Playstation 3 is being sold
we're looking at
other options.
And if that's something that
you're interested in pursuing
you should talk to me.
AUDIENCE: Among other things
it seems to me that the
lightweight mechanism for
keeping the stack from
stomping on other things --
PROFESSOR: I think that
this is very new area.
Before you put things in
hardware, you need to have
some kind of consensus, what's
the right way to do it?
This is a bare metal that
gives you huge amount of
opportunity but you give enough
rope to hang yourself.
And the key thing is you can get
all this performance and
what will happen perhaps, in the
next few years is people
come up to consensus
saying, look,
everybody has to do this.
Everybody needs MPI, everybody
needs this cache.
And slowly, some of those
features will do a little bit
of a feature creep, so you're
going to have they little bit
of overhead, little bit
less power efficient.
But it will be much
easier to program.
But this is kind of the bare
metal thing that to get and in
some sense, it's a nice time
because I think in 5 years if
you look at cell you won't have
this level of access.
You'll have all this nice build
on top up in doing this
so, this is a unique
positioning there.
It's very hard to deal with, but
also on the other hand you
get to see underneath.
You get to see without any
kind of these sort
of things in there.
So my feeling is in a few years
you'll get all those
things put back.
When and if we figure out how
to deal with things like
segmentation on the multicore
with very fine grain
communication and there's a lot
of issues here that you
need to figure out.
But right now all those issues
are [INAUDIBLE].
It's like OK, we don't
know how to do it.
Well, you go figure it out OK?
MICHAEL PERRONE: Thank
you very much.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
I don't have that much
more material.
So I have about 10,
15 minutes.
Do you guys need a break
or should we just go
directly to the end?
How many people say
we want a break?